it really is a pleasure to see you in
this context sacred say cheese damn it
you look beautiful can you give us a
little more information surrounding the
deficits that you're running this year
oh gosh we don't really like to talk
about you find it a little gauche this
is a budget meeting well most of our
files are in these boxes if you really
want to take a look at how much that
we've spent why don't we just dig in and
see what we're up against
yes and thank you we really appreciate
your help
are you tipping me is that a hundred
euros Walter Gunderson serves Pawnee for
39 years and as per his final wish his
body will lie in state in the City
Council Chambers for a day which is just
a real cool thing for a public space
also he sent us a brief video message to
be played for this event hello Pawnee my
time in office has come to an end a lot
has been done but I wasn't really doing
very much I wasn't paying attention most
of the time fortunately the citizens of
Pawnee didn't pay attention either so if
there's credit to take I will humbly
take it and if there is blame it's your
fault thank you and goodbye forever okay
well that was really something
let's see I can't figure this thing out
can you help me yeah just hang on a
second Bobby ink all over my hands and a
pen thing you came up the chain I don't
get it what are you doing Oh Leslie well
since you decided to drag my name
through the mud on TV I figured why not
return the favor Oh could you quietly
quiet down for a second and please tell
me what's going on quietly okay in a
quiet voice a citizen handed in a very
interesting home video that I think the
people of Pawnee will find very
interesting take a peek at this keep
your eyes on the creek there he is oh
this is my favorite part not willing to
share with a dog so it would appear that
Park security was not to blame after all
okay look I have a proposition for you
fine I'll have sex with you in exchange
for the tape know what I'm saying
okay just listen to what I have to say I
directly oversee 1200 people I have a
staff of creative geniuses that will not
stop working until we win this bid
Leslie I couldn't find that file you
wanted but I did find a file called bird
census 1980 and it's empty get out of
your head I fired you right if anybody
wants to hang I will be at Subway
he's very stupid
so far so good admitted things are going
surprisingly well and pack it up it's
over we're screwed
keep artists girlfriend what's this
twister brain's girlfriend Ben Oh Ben
your father brought his little plaything
hi Benny
hey Dad hi Lonnie thought you weren't
coming Lonnie is my girlfriend and she's
important to me and I need her here
Lonnie hi I'm Leslie what a wonderful
surprise we're so happy that you're here
what the hell Steve they didn't know I
was coming we didn't know it was spring
break
okay thanks everybody for coming I'm so
sorry you all have to go home hey Red
Vines anyone we're a Twizzlers family do
you really expect me to believe that
what does he got a cute wimping out no
he has kidney stones we have proof yeah
I took a video of him at the hospital an
hour ago I feel like I never gave Miles
Davis proper shrift like get into it
well good news is I'm here to accept the
key on his behalf
oh it's just a real shame it had to
happen today of all days damn it Ron Ron
last name Doug is that your name or are
you telling me you're finished talking
booth done and done I like Ron okay
Eagleton Ron tell me a little about
yourself well I love the outdoors love
nature a man I'm a big believer in
environmental conservation recycling and
composting and alike I'm a yoga net and
I'm nut nut they make delicious milk man
and of a vegan of course slowly working
towards bull freaking the vegan what in
God's name is friggin vegan you only eat
vegetables that have been thrown out in
people's dumpsters sir you can't go in
there
aha I caught you hey it's Tom what the
hell are you doing what am i doing what
are you doing here dr. Saperstein is
giving me a sonogram in his doctor's
office for women because I'm pregnant
oh my god you're John Rafael's dad
you're the one that's trying to put me
out of business
Wow look at that mr. Haverford you track
me down looks like your detective skills
are a lot better than your tween
high-end fashion rental skills and Chris
can we have the room please no you
certainly cannot dr. Saperstein where
are you doing this what did I ever do to
you you know exactly why I'm doing this
you destroyed my family first you
screwed my son out of your business and
then you stole my daughter's virginity
[Laughter]
wait you're serious deadly serious
according to my daughter you broke her
heart then you smashed up her BMW I had
to buy her a new one so she could drive
the divinity school let me tell you
something mister you attack us a
pristine you face my wrath
be so sure about this tiny Tom that I
will crush you like the bug you are and
there it is the heart beat everything
sounds perfect oh this is the money were
dreamin of you and me and our baby and
Tom and his weird feud with our doctor
that's a big cheering section okay
that's Conchords all on Mongolia she
grew up in a hut that was entirely made
of ice and mud then she became their
mayor then their police chief and their
best Wolverine Wrangler I loved her Oh
hey you must be Leslie Knope Emily
Danson I'm one of the honorees oh look
at your face good it's just so
symmetrical I'm Molly bangs you know we
all have that in Denmark oh you're from
Denmark of course what perm Denmark are
you from I'm from silk of work you know
it's not one of the most perfect places
in the world but I love it and it loves
me and look what they've done for me I
mean a statue of you Wow is that goat
cheese good cheese I Leslie it is made
out of goat cheese we have a lot of it
and after tonight's event
they're gonna consume me with crackers
they just love me what about your town
well Pawnee Indiana is a wonderful town
and I love it but they hate me and
they're trying to kick me out of office
one time they made a pinata of my face
and then everybody in the town came and
took turns hitting it with a stick and
they filled it with broccoli just to add
insult to injury but politics you know
what I mean right the best lunch I ever
had I have to see the photos that you
took I didn't take any photos Leslie
you're treating those people like
they're your heroes they could be your
peers look I really hope you take the
job but we're at the end of the line
here I need a decision by tomorrow okay
that's fair I mean I would be insane not
to take the job but I'm just having some
trouble thinking about leaving Pawnee
hey here's someone who may be able to
convince you hello mrs. Obama hey grant
how you doing good good this is Leslie
Knope she's considering a job with us
running the new Midwest Bureau in
Chicago well you know how I feel about
Chicago you are from Chicago so you like
it that's right and we need passionate
people like you in our national parks
you know they get hundreds of millions
of visitors each year are you nodding
because you agree with me yes I do agree
with you I agree with you on all things
throughout history until the end of time
forever you and grant work together yeah
we work together a lot he's helped me
integrate the Let's Move program into
our national parks you know getting kids
outside
rock climbing hiking wow that's really
really incredible great work I'm sorry
I'm talking so loud I'm getting louder
now and I can't stop my apologies just
I don't know yeah well I hope you take
the job change happens one person at a
time
good to meet you
[Applause]
again think it over
[Laughter]
you